all right so when all this happens uh
i was not paying a lot of attention then
all of a sudden when it started to like
really really go up people started
tweeting it at me so i kind of spent my
obligatory like you know 20 minutes
googling okay
i kind of sort of understand it just
enough to to know what
bucket to put it in mentally but didn't
really go deep on it
and then all of a sudden when uh the
treasury was taken
literally my feed was just filled with
anger hate
laughing i mean just every emotion in
the world coming from different people
uh the i told you so crowd the somebody
stole my money because i don't
understand what actually happened crowd
the
you know the token went down yeah i mean
just everything uh
and so i was like okay that's probably
not a good development for uh for
people um and then i don't know
24 hours later uh somebody tweets at me
and says
hey it's been transferred as a project
to you and i was like wait what is going
on so kind of how did that happen and
what exactly happened i guess
yeah um that was uh that was pretty
pretty [ __ ] wild so uh um
yeah i was uh i mean
i like many people were not excited
about the developments with the treasury
i think i was like a little more
sympathetic than than some people were
just in that i thought that there was
legitimate ambiguity about what had been
intended
um not that i thought this was an
appropriate use of them
but that i i also sort of felt like like
legitimately like people didn't quite
nail down what what the plan was for it
and also that like nomi seemed
legitimately not
to think that this was going to be
perceived the way it was
like there seemed to be a real like this
wasn't sort of like him saying all by
you know this there's like a real
disconnect here um
but i but also sort of destroyed the
project and
also was the wrong thing to do and uh
and like you know it was also not
selfishly the right thing to do i mean
it
made everyone off he's bad bad for
everyone like it's
and you know the honest truth is if like
he had never done that
and just like worked really hard for the
project
and made it be a great thing and then
eventually sort of like hey guys
like like i think that like you know
i should get a percent of the tokens i
think people have been like yeah that
sounds right
you know that sounds like like you
deserve that
and i thank you could have ended up with
more than they
did so um so how does it get transferred
to you
yeah so i i wrote some some tweet
threads
expressing expressing my displeasure and
um
and uh you know basically like you gotta
[ __ ] transfer control this project or
it's just dead
like you no one is gonna have faith in
it with you
with the keys like sort of like uh and
um anyway i serve like uh that socks
like that that's sort of it for sushi
um and i don't know took a nap and
i i was like on a beanbag
by my desk and sort of just shouted out
like hey someone just tweeted that nomi
said he was gonna give you the keys
uh and it was as a weird moment um
but i i don't know i come got up and you
know bolted to my
computer and and in fact so manhattan
tweeted a screenshot of nomi saying he
was gonna give me the keys to the
treasury
um so that's pretty weird and uh
and i mean it was like uh kind of like
an even more bizarre twist than the
freakiest twist of him having taken like
like he sort of like you know was like
a really strong negative twist and then
an even weirder positive twist
um but i but yeah i mean
i don't know he he then did it like he
he sent the keys to the
the treasury and um
and that sort of changed my weekend
plans
i mean you know whatever i i had thought
i was gonna do
it wasn't figure out how to do a sushi
migration
um but remember the migration hadn't
hadn't happened yet
like that still had to happen and it was
actually kind of a tricky intricate
process
and i mean we like i hadn't written
sushi
swap or anything sort of like you know
so all of a sudden it's like okay
like i guess what's happening this
weekend
is uh that
we're gonna go figure out how sushi swap
works
you still have control right uh
so we are uh so the key was with was
passed and sort of like technological
control
over some parts of it although uh
you know as sort of dictated by votes of
community
members um but that control is
transferring to a
to multisig control okay sort of step
one
and that transference is happening maybe
tonight um
we we have everyone's address now and
uh last i checked in we're preparing it
so uh that's going to be sort of the
next step for
uh you know the next step for for sushi
swap in
sort of formally you know removing me of
control which is sort of important to it
because that's not it's not sam swap
and it's not you know i'm not meant to
run it i don't run it i don't like
it sort of like the keys were dropped on
me but it's that's not
i it's it's you know meant to be the
communities project
and so so you have no plans this is not
going to become the next
product line of alameda's to go
[Laughter]
no this is not and it's it sort of can't
be because
that's not like it would involve
fundamentally changing what sushi swap
is you know like that's you know if if
you know if i like at some point you
know
serum might create or fdx or something
might
create you know name a deck something
like that but yes serum did create dex
but
um i you know sushi swap sort of dropped
on
my lap and i want to be sort of faithful
to like what it was meant to be
and what people thought it was meant to
be when they
got involved in it